So to access a particular class,
click its tab at the top.
So let's click the GT1001 class that
we've created for this orientation.
For most classes, when you access
the class you'll see a screen like this.
On the left,
you'll see a sidebar of links.
In the middle, you will see some
basic information about the course,
such as the syllabus,
start dates, and important links.
On the right side, you will see
the recent course announcements.
You will use all of these
tools throughout the course.
Later, we will talk about Piazza,
Udacity, and Peer Feedback, but for
right now, let's talk about Assignments,
Gradebook,
Tests & Quizzes, and Resources.